forme de la chasse at elle précipité le
départ de nicolas hulot deux mesures
phares ont été annoncés hier par
l'elysée
le permis national passera de 400 à 200
euros et la gestion des espèces
chassables sera évolutive en fonction du
contexte des avancées saluées par les
chasseurs ce sont évidemment des choses
qui voit dans le bon sens puisque ça va
créer du pouvoir d'achat selon les
chasseurs sont comme tous les ans ou
tous les citoyens donc 200 de moins de
100 euros de moins de pourchasser donc
c'est toujours bon à prendre et la
gestion adaptative semble être un bon
moyen pour continuer à chasser
quand ça va le permettre et savoir aussi
s'arrêter cathy froide s'activera
s'arrêter mais les mesures critiquées
dans les écologistes ont peut être été
la goutte d'eau de trop pour nicolas
hulot sa démission ce mardi matin a été
une surprise pour la députée perry moule
et pas toujours en phase avec le
ministre notamment sur le nucléaire elle
regrette les reproches dont il a fait
l'objet au cours des derniers mois je
trouve ça dommage voilà parce que je
pense que ses qualités ses défauts mais
un sens de l'écologie qui va je pense
perdurer au gouvernement promet un
départ qui résonne comme un constat
d'échec pour les écologistes élus
d'opposition à nevers wilfrid séjeau
pointe le poids des lobbys au
gouvernement mais il craint que la
portée des questions environnementales
ne diminue encore sans nicolas hulot
effectivement il n'y a aucune
corrélation entre ce qu'on voit la
dégradation de l'environnement et de
l'impact sur les êtres humains et sur la
biodiversité
et puis les décisions politiques ne sont
absolument pas à la hauteur je pense que
c'est une voie importante qui va
disparaître je vois pas qui mieux que
nicolas hulot pouvait porter les enjeux
écologiques au sein de ce gouvernement
malheureusement il a été désavoué d'une
certaine façon y part parce que le
gouvernement ne l'a pas suivie par qui
n'a pas été écouté le nom du successeur
de nicolas hulot à la tête du ministère
sera donc scruté avec attention
en attendant de savoir si il ou elle
pourra peser dans les enjeux à venir
[Applaudissements]